WHAT A SHOT
2:21, IT IS OVER IN THE
TRADE FOR
GREAT CONNECTIVITY ON THE BACK
SCREEN ACTION  PASS
PARTICULAR STALE AND JIEIGHT ST
DRIBBLE UP THE PHYSICALITY
IT BACK.
JOHN: LOWRFINAL SIX SECONDS AND
MAGIC BY 13 HERE AT HALFTIME AT
THE
STATE CHAMPIONSHIPS.
THEN HE WENT ON TO MUNFORD
ACADEMY. PAINT WHAT
BUTLER.
GRAYSON ALLEN.
THE STEP BACK. STEP BACK. NOTHI
BUT
GOT T
THEY LEAD BY 21.BUTLER, POWER M.
SIX POINTS. FRANZ
WAGNER WARM-UP.
HE'S'SBY 30.
BUTLER.
DEDMAN. THAT
>> John: THANASIS ANTETOKOUNMPO
IS FLAILING AROU
AND GET TO THAT FREE-THROW LINE.
FOR MIAMI.ING TO
BUTLER DRIVES ON ONE.
AND OUBRE, NO FOR DEDMON AND TH.
GREA
SHUTDOWN ON THE L EATING THE RE
AND THEN YOU JUST BACK
THREE-POINT RANGE.
ADEBAYO!
TO COME UP
WITH A IN MIAMI
BEFORE THAT.
BETTER THAN INTRI
SADDIQ BEY DEFENDING BUTLER. Y S
BAM ADEBAYO AND HE PLAYS ALL
HE'S GOT 27 LAST NIGHT.
THEY HAD 72 IN THE THE FLOOR.
JUST GREAT AWARENESS.
WATCH HOW HE SWIVELS HE
JUMPED INTO THE PASSING LANE.N.
ROUND TWO AGAINST THE CLIPPERS
JOHN: HE IS TALENTED.
THEY NEED TO SCORE BADLY RIGHT
NOW IF YOU ARE MIAMI.
BUTLER.
JIMMY BRINGS UP AGAINST COLLINSY
AVDIJA.
DEWAYNE